hi my name is Randy Keith and I'm from  San Diego California i graduated from  Linfield christian school in 2012 and  i'm currently a political economy major  at hillsdale college this spring I'm  interning for the council for national  policy as part of the Washington  Hillsdale internship program the  Washington Hillsdale internship program  we call a whip for short we bring  anywhere between 10 to 20 students a  semester out to DC they take two or  three classes and they in turn on the  hill at the Heritage Foundation really  anywhere they want to we find somebody  coming out of college who has some  practical real-world experience  especially experience that applies to  what we do it really sets them apart  Washington is one of those places that  kids can learn a lot and gain a lot just  from being here for a few months and  that sense coming here and having that  in turn experience i can guarantee will  be life-changing  you